a good afternoon Miroslav colleagues
students I apologize for being out of
town today on a day when we're talking
about my favorite subject which is
markets and businesses and the human
characteristics that are functional in
market systems and their relationship to
religious teaching and education and are
supportable from a religious point of
view let me put this together under six
headings I'll I'll do all this in five
or ten minutes in preparation this
morning have reviewed the ten
commandments and the first three or four
don't seem to have much direct bearing
on market societies and the one which is
probably most foundational has to do
with telling the truth not bearing false
witness and let's call this the
integrity package the fit between to my
knowledge all religion and the basic
norm of truth is pretty powerful and
that basic norm is absolutely
foundational to the way markets work one
way to look at it is not committing
fraud not labeling something organic and
marking up the price when you grew it
with chemicals another is when you're in
an employment situation where you're the
employee and there is a an
organizational goal and you have a task
to do
that that goal insofar as you're
committed as an employee has to be your
goal it has to become internalized and
you've got to got to take that seriously
and put it ahead of competing personal
goals if you look at the most important
and dramatic meltdowns
in market systems over the last decade a
very high fraction of them have to do
with breaches of integrity the ninja
mortgages written knowingly across the
country ninja meaning no job no income
no assets were written in bad faith and
the bad faith was institutionalized and
everybody understood what it was and it
was just wrong and similarly the
off-balance sheet partnerships which
Enron used to hide debt and hide failed
projects from investors fell in the same
category so the the integrity package is
a big and important one a second one I
think is openness to difference the
great run-up in productivity that market
societies have exhibited over the last
let's say 200 years has a lot to do with
learning to see talent through or beyond
a script of identities beyond the
question is this a man or a woman is
this a Hindu or a Muslim is this a
Christian or a Jew
the question instead is is this a person
who can do this job well or the question
is to whom shall we market and the
answer is that cash is green no matter
what the ax script of identity of the
people who buy the product the
overcoming in the United States of
arbitrary prejudice based on race and
gender both of them enormous progress
has been made in the last two
generations and the in every field the
demonstration that fresh talent of the
highest order comes from every
descriptive group is a really important
point and it's a point which is
certainly consistent with the
judeo-christian tradition and I think
with with all of the others the third is
what people call a work ethic the notion
of defining value in one's productive
life in seeing excellence and
craftsmanship and ingenuity invested in
a job as a personal value not something
one does to get to the end of the day
and collect the paycheck but something
one does because it's part of who who
she or he is fourth what some people in
the management world call cognitive
empathy being able to see how the world
looks
from other people's point of view and
training that capacity so that in
organizing people to do a task or merely
being part of a team organizing itself
being able to look around the room and
see that the same task may look very
differently to various members of the
group
similarly cognitive empathy in marketing
products to people whose tastes and
values or needs are very different from
your own being able to imagine how the
world looks from a wheelchair in doing
architecture for example or in product
design so cognitive empathy is a fourth
one the fifth one and perhaps the most
trite is is a sense of thrift a sense of
economy a willingness to fit the fit the
resources used to accomplish a task or
produce a product to the economic
constraints of of the problem and being
willing and able to think with some
ingenuity about about them the highest
and best use of any given resource
finally sixth and last living a long
time having a long and reasonably
healthy life if you want to want to say
what has provided more fuel to market
societies in the global age than
anything else it is probably the world
demographic transition which has allowed
allowed workers to have long careers and
to get better and better as they go and
to be able to afford to stay in school
as many of you are well into there
twenties and in a few cases fred beyond
that so there we are
I'll be back next week and I'm sure
Miroslav has lots of wonderful stuff for
you to do during the rest of this class
goodbye